all right welcome everybody another day
another emergency White House
coronavirus briefing this was there's
some folks in the chat who seemed to
think this was scheduled for 11:30 and
that they're late they probably will be
late but as you can see from Donald
Trump's schedule it was scheduled for
11:45 all along and these have been
starting anywhere from 15 to 45 minutes
late so anyone's guests anyone's guests
when it is that this is going to start
but we will be on it officially seven
and a half minutes until this starts I
know from the e-mails I'm getting a lot
of our audience is just extremely bored
people are increasingly at home I am
going to talk about shelter and place
orders I'll also talk about rumors of
shelter and place orders that are wrong
I want to talk about what we're seeing
here in Massachusetts there's some
confusion about chloroquine thanks to
Donald Trump's as usual muddled
explanation yesterday of what's going on
usually some combination of truths
half-truths lies and incompetence that's
sort of how I would sum up everything
folks also talking about what's going to
happen to the census I also wanted to
talk about that let me make a note here
census I filled out my census form
yesterday and it was actually tough I
don't know that I'm going to end up
getting a very high score on my census
form because I actually found some of
the questions a little bit confusing
welcome if you're just joining us we are
live on YouTube twitch and Facebook
standing by for a white house
coronavirus briefing where to start
let's see where I don't even know what
to start with so I did go to Trader
Joe's this morning in Brookline
Brookline technically not Boston legally
speaking but it's one of the
neighborhoods that's part of the Greater
Boston area spoke to some of the
employees at Trader Joe's much more calm
fully fully stocked on just about
everything they had toilet paper they
had everything and I was able to pick up
a bunch of stuff and the employees there
said it there's a lot less panic buying
a lot of people bought a whole bunch of
stuff a week ago and then now they're
realizing we
more than enough stuff now we don't need
to keep going and buying so a lot less
panic buying fully stocked people are
calm the parking lot was not going crazy
the police officers that normally have
to be managing the traffic at the
Brookline Trader Joe's parking lot we're
sitting across the street the guy one of
the police officers was reading a novel
so that gives you a sense of people
really are staying in unless they need
to go out we don't have a shelter in
place here in Massachusetts now let me
talk about that next okay oh and by the
way when I came out of the Trader Joe's
I went directly over to Michael's deli
and stocked up on pastrami and knishes
and you know just the basic things you
need it to get through being home and
and that sort of thing so let's see
Massachusetts okay that's what I wanted
to get to next in general okay the total
case numbers that we're seeing and this
is world ometer zod info slash
coronavirus I think this is this is the
the best site for this although there
there are a bunch of different ones the
the numbers here in a lot of ways aren't
very useful so for example the United
States now having 14,000 549 cases the
number is likely between a hundred and
forty thousand and you know 500 or 750
thousand or even a million cases we
found out that the Boston Celtics player
Marcus smart has coronavirus he feels
completely fine he threw up ten days ago
vomiting seems to be prevalent in
somewhere between 8 and 13 percent of
coronavirus cases it may or may not have
been related but he just feels fine if
it weren't for the fact that he was able
to get a test despite feeling fine
because the NBA has a problem now he
would never know that he had coronavirus
he'd be at the gym spreading it to
people etc so the point is this number
is going up because we are testing more
but realistically there are so many more
cases however what I do want to show you
is if we drill down at the
state-by-state information for the
United States you will notice that
Massachusetts now is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
Massachusetts has been doing more
testing and we are falling in terms of
how many cases we have
we started not shelter-in-place but
governor Charlie Baker a Republican who
has been big-picture managing this okay
and there's actually some interesting
video of him confronting Trump yesterday
on that governor's call and saying what
you're telling us to do isn't working
but we'll save that for later in
Massachusetts governor Charlie Baker
said no more school just school is done
for the time being
restaurants can do takeout and delivery
only tons of retail has just shut down
if you go to new Erick Newbury Street
restaurants of course are takeout only
but a lot of the retail stores around
said there's just no people we're gonna
shut down completely Massachusetts was
in the top three in cases a week ago we
are now down to ninth or tenth not
because we aren't testing we are
actually doing quite a bit of testing in
Massachusetts these strategies work okay
we are depressing the curve and I I only
mentioned this I you may notice that of
all the states that are on the screen
right now that that have you know over
300 cases Massachusetts so far has not
had any deaths now that's statistically
unlikely to continue but we are doing
something more than for example governor
Ron de santis in Florida yesterday shut
down the beaches up until yesterday you
had thousands and thousands of people
partying on beaches and complaining
about what's going on the point is this
stuff works California now has more
cases last night the Los Angeles mayor
as well as the governor have issued
different shelter-in-place
orders of different strictness my
brothers living in Los Angeles and yeah
and and and to be clear part of the
Massachusetts numbers are that we the
system is not yet overwhelmed so that
that gives you better care it reduces
the likelihood of people dying but it's
close I know doctors who were on
vacation and were called back to Boston
because the system is starting to get
overwhelmed the president of Mass
General Hospital one of the premier
hospitals in the country has asked that
people download the instructions for 3d
printing masks start printing them and
getting them to Mass General we're doing
stuff here okay that's the point but we
are now seeing more shelter-in-place
orders
California it appears as though
Pennsylvania's going in that direction
we are starting to see National Guard
mobilized in different parts I'm hearing
anecdotally that people are being
activated in the National Guard for
potentially up to 30 days or longer
there was what seems to be sort of a I
don't want to call it bogus but I got a
text from one person that was a
screenshot that basically said I have a
friend in the Pennsylvania governor's
office lockdown is coming it's going to
last a little bit and then someone else
sent me it's almost identical except it
said a friend of mine in the Department
of Defense says and it was otherwise
identical that seems to be one of these
memes that has been spreading virally
and some governors have denied that they
are actually doing that I'm hopeful that
in Massachusetts we won't even have to
go to shelter in place but things are
getting confusing because on the one
hand there are false text message is
spreading claiming shelter in place is
coming everywhere at the same time there
are shelters in place starting in some
states so we just have to listen to to
authorities and see what's going on but
if there is anything positive to find in
the numbers it's that in Massachusetts
we started a week ago and we went from
third in cases to ninth or tenth despite
the fact that we are doing a lot a lot
of tests here so this stuff matters and
you know pay attention to it okay
let me get some thank yous out of the
way first and then we will get back to
the material as we wait here neuro
plastic Odyssey and Captain ACO have
both subscribed on Twitch thanks to both
of you
I appreciate that I also want to say
thanks to Phyllis constant who is new
member number one today at join
pakman.com as well as Andrew Argento
Andrew Argento is new member number two
at join pakman.com and Martin Fillion
Martin Fillion is new member number
three at join pakman.com thank you very
much I appreciate that
and so you know what we're far as the
free stuff giveaways yesterday I said
I'll give away a free item
the david pakman show store for members
5 10 15 20 and 25 and people in the
audience rightly said David that's
that's not a good idea because people
will just wait until you get to 4 or
whatever so instead what we're doing is
I'm just gonna randomly gift 5 10 15 20
I'm gonna randomly gift 5 items when we
get to 25 members will email you and let
you know what we've we've picked people
almost everybody going with the data
mail t-shirts which we made available on
the website yesterday I'll show that to
you just because we have time here and
we're hanging out we have a new t-shirt
data mail which is a it we are
prominently fighting back against this
concept of beta mail and so you can get
a data mail t-shirt the most popular
colors are actually heather gray and
banana cream banana cream is very very
popular I get that the contrast on some
of these other colors isn't great but
we're already shipping dozens of these
all over the world it's incredible yeah
this one we've got to deal with
maybe we just need different a different
color graphic for this one but yeah so
anyway we we will instead of doing free
items at 5 10 15 20 25 members will do
every 5 I'll give one out to someone and
we will go by that ok super chats are
coming in ac asks your opinion on the
$1200 one-time payment I've been out all
morning so I actually don't know if
anything has been made definitive yet
I'm hearing all sorts of different
things so let's just wait and see what
Trump announces and then we'll analyze
it I just don't know what is actually
going to going going to be offered
Marika says Finland ranked happiest
country in the world third year in a row
why we have toilet paper
Jason Aldridge says Governor Cuomo just
shut down 100% of non-essential
workforce in New York that's interesting
yeah ice it looks as though Cuomo right
now is holding a press conference
[Music]
I don't know I can get you the break-up
do you know off the top of your head the
audio is atrocious so we'll get away
from that for now but yes at in a number
of different states you are starting to
see the shelter's in place going in
Alexis beat now interestingly enough
understand part of the reason why New
York may have to do that is because they
didn't do what Massachusetts did early
enough and now they have almost 6,000
cases Massachusetts again I'm not
bragging I just happened to live here
it's just coincidence but Wheaton
nobody's been really going out for a
week already and we've gone from third
in cases to tenth despite more testing
so the earlier you do this stuff this
whole concept this meme of depressed the
curve flatten the curve it's a real
thing it's a very very real thing
Alexis B says thank you for letting me
know that the Trader Joe's a block from
home is stocked and safe I'm high risk
and was haired scared to go five dollars
for your next trip thanks Alexis yeah
Trader Joe's in Brookline very well
stocked all employees seem to be wearing
gloves and being careful people are
being respectful and they had everything
I was even you know one of my favorite
favorite Trader Joe's items is the
smoked trout tins that they have last
time I went to the Brookline Trader
Joe's they were all out of those and I
grabbed a couple today I'm not getting
it you know I don't need trout for the
next year but I got a couple of smoked
trout tins excellent excellent
with a little cream cheese on a
whole-wheat cracker you can't you really
can't go wrong with that smoked trout
okay Joey Gomez says I'm from Montana I
feel blessed we don't have many cases
but still have everything closing yeah
here's the thing there are going to be
measures that feel like they are too
much but then in retrospect we'll be
able to say the fact that it was it felt
like too much is what hopefully stopped
this from being even on the air with
today's update on the corona virus
pandemic the latest numbers are as
follows oh my god okay so we don't need
to listen to Chuck Todd but we are it
looks like we are very very close to the
start is that Ivanka I don't know if you
guys knew but if Trump
wasn't related to Ivanka he would be
interested in dating her he said that a
number of times I'm guessing that they
have a larger delegation here today
because they are going to be announcing
the cash payments or whatever the case
may be so we are that that's my sense of
the situation okay let me say thank you
to a couple other new members Anthony
Borghese is new member number four today
at join pakman.com and oh I got more
excited than I needed to be I thought I
had a few other people to think we are
thank you I appreciate that we were at 4
of 25 members today okay Matt Chavez
says what will be done about the
Republican senators who sold stock after
being briefed about the virus months ago
essentially committing insider trading I
don't know I don't know but it's
disgusting and we'll cover that on on
the show on Monday Mecca 101 says I saw
states building hospitals in some areas
couldn't they come into your convention
centers instead you know in Spain they
have hotels being turned into hospitals
we are seeing sort of tent hospitals and
and and that sort of thing here is
Donald Trump let's let's take a listen
thank you very much I had a very good
telephone conversation extremely good
with Senator Schumer a little while ago
we're working on various elements of the
deal and the Democrats are very much
wanting something to happen and the
Republicans likewise are very much
wanting something to happen and I think
it will I spoke with a dealings with
Mitch McConnell and this tremendous
spirit to get something done so we'll
see what happens but my conversation was
very good with Senator Schumer I thank
you all for joining us and I'd like to
begin by providing an update on what we
are doing to minimize the impact of the
Chinese virus on our nation's students
of God with many schools closed due to
the virus the Department of Education
will not enforce standardized testing
requirements very importantly ogre
students in elementary through high
school for the current year
they've been through a lot they've been
going back and forth schools open
schools not open it's been all
standardized testing and you know it's
we're not going to be enforcing that so
I think you can let the people know I
think probably a lot of the students
would be extremely happy some probably
not the ones that work hard maybe not
but it's one of those things unfortunate
very unfortunate circumstance we've also
temporarily waived all interest on
federally held student loans they'll be
very happy to hear that and I've
instructed them to take that action
immediately and today secretary divorces
directed federal lenders to allow
borrowers to suspend their student loans
and loan payments without penalty for at
least the next 60 days and if we need
more we'll extend that period of time
borrowers should contact their lenders
but we've given them very strong
instructions so we've temporarily waived
all interest one federally held student
loans that's a big thing that's gonna
make a lot of students very happy and we
have more to come when student loans
more good news for the students but
we'll do that at a different time this
morning the Treasury Department also
announced that we're moving tax day from
April 15th to July 15th so we're we're
moving it out to July 15th so that
people will have time and people will be
able to hopefully by that time we'll
have people getting back to their lives
families and businesses will have this
extra time to file with no interest or
penalties we're getting rid of interest
and penalties however if you have
refunds or credits you would like to
claim you may still file in other words
you can file early if not yet borrowed
money by the IRS already got one other
than that we're moving it all the way
out to July 15th no interest no
penalties your new date will be July
15th today our team will also provide an
update on our continuing effort to
prevent the transmission of viruses
America's borders and
I watched what's been happening in
California with governor Newsom and this
morning with Governor Cuomo and I
applaud them they're taking very strong
both steps and I applaud them and we're
all working together we're working very
closely together including those two
governors but I would say based on the
call the media was there I think we can
say that with respect to virtually every
governor in that Co I think every
governor we had almost all of them if
not all of them and I would say that you
could see for yourselves at the level of
respect and esprit de corps working
together was very good more there was no
nobody angry nobody upset we're able to
help them and that's what we're all
about we want to help we're doing things
that a lot of people wouldn't be able to
do but the relationship with governors
and States's I think very extraordinary
especially under the circumstances where
this just came upon us we're working
with Canada and Mexico to prevent the
spread of the virus across North America
very closely you heard what we did
yesterday with Canada and Secretary of
State Pompeyo will be making a statement
in a little while having to do with
Mexico and the border and Chad likewise
Chad woeful likewise be making a
statement
nobody's joint comprehensive effort in
collaboration with our neighbors the
measure and all of those measures that
we're putting in place will protect the
health of all three nations and reduce
the incentive for a mass global
migration that would badly deplete the
healthcare resources needed for our
people and so we are working very
closely with Mexico very very closely
with with Canada the relationships never
been better we're all working for the
same toward the same goal our nation's
top health care officials are extremely
concerned about the grave public health
consequences of mass uncontrolled
cross-border movement
and that would be mostly and even beyond
but mostly during this global pandemic
every week our border agents encounter
thousands of unscreened unvetted and
unauthorized entries from dozens of
countries and we've had this problem for
decades for decades why is that now it's
with the national emergencies and all of
the other things that we've declared we
can actually do something about it we're
taking a very strong hold of that and we
have before but this is now at a level
that nobody's ever approached in normal
times these massive flows place of s
burden on our healthcare system but
during a global pandemic they threatened
to create a perfect storm that would
spread the infection to our border
agents migrants and to the public at
large left unchecked this would [ __ ]
our immigration system overwhelm our
health care system and severely damaged
our national security we're not going to
let that happen so we have a lot of
information and they'll be discussing
that in a moment to confront these
public health degrees the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention has
decided to exercise its authority under
the title 42 of the u.s. code to give
customers and border protection the
tools it needs to prevent the
transmission of the virus coming through
both the northern and the southern
borders so we're treating the borders
equally the northern border and the
southern border it's being treated
they're both being treated equally a lot
of people say that they're not treated
equally well they are oh as we did with
Canada we're also working with Mexico to
implement new rules at our ports of
entry to suspend non-essential travel
these new rules and procedures will not
impede lawful trade and commerce
furthermore Mexico is taking action to
secure our own southern border and
suspend air travel from Europe so we're
coordinating very closely the air travel
going to Mexico and then trying to come
in to the United States the actions were
together with our North American
partners will save countless lives at
the conclusion of my remarks secretary
azar secretary Pompeo secretary wolf
we're going to be also taking some
questions with Tony and Debra who you've
gotten to know very well but they'll be
discussing certain things and I think
you'll find them of great interest we're
gonna be providing tremendous amounts of
detail over the coming days but a lot of
it will be provided right now if you'd
like to find out about it just keep what
has been a week of resolute action
tremendous action tremendous
relationships have developed for the
people that frankly didn't get along
people that didn't like each other
they're now working together and maybe
even in some cases learning about each
other and liking each other it's nice
thing I invoked the defense production
act and last night we put it into gear
we move the National Response
Coordination Center to the highest level
of activation if you if you take a look
at what we did the level of activation
has been increased to a grade one level
which is the highest level we're
providing historic support to small
businesses and to the states the states
need support normally they do this
themselves because of the magnitude of
it the federal government has gotten
very much involved in terms of getting
the equipment they need so we're helping
them it's it's a responsibility they
have but we are helping the states a lot
that's why the governors I think in
every case have been impressed and very
nice we enacted legislation guaranteeing
paid sick leave governors are for
workers at no cost to employers and I
think it's very important so they get
paid sick leave at no cost to employers
we're accelerating the use of new drug
treatments were advancing legislation to
give direct payments to hardworking
families throughout our country
Americans from all walks of life are
rallying
defeat the unseen enemy striking our
nation in times of struggle we see the
true greatness of the American character
and we are saying that a lot of people
are talking about it we're in a hundred
and forty-one countries from what
they're telling me and some of those
countries are really working in a
unified manner and they're working very
unified with us almost I could say good
good number of them doctors and nurses
are working nonstop to heal the sick
citizens and churches are delivering
meals to the needy truckers are making
the long haul to keep shelves stop we've
been dealing with the big stores and the
big chains Walmart they've been
fantastic and others they've all been
fantastic fantastic we've made it much
easier for them to stock in terms of
travel and travel restrictions we're
lifting restrictions so they can get
their trucks on time you're seeing very
few empty shelves and yet the amount of
volume that they're doing is
unprecedented because people want to
have what they have to have what they
feel they have to have and they're also
buying in slightly smaller quantities
which is good data true because we're
not going anywhere we're gonna be here
so I want to thank all of those very
great companies for working so well
Americans from every walk of life are
coming together and thanks to the spirit
of our people we will win this war we
are we're winning and we're going to win
this war the invisible America will
triumph and America will rise higher
than ever before we'll be stronger than
ever before and we've learned a lot
we've learned a lot we've learned a lot
about relying on other countries and I
can say that I think in both a very good
and a very bad way some good things came
out of it and some not-so-good things
came out of it so I'd like to move now
to invite our team to provide
information on the new measures to
prevent viral spread and oh and I'll
start by asking Secretary of State
Pompeyo to speak he's doing a fantastic
job and like everyone else he's been
working very very long and very
very hard and he's fearing the other
more normal jobs of a great Secretary of
State but he got he got tied into this
like everybody else and he's been really
doing a fantastic job Mike place you
can't get through one sentence without
very tremendous fantastic Thank You mr.
president
before I address the efforts that we've
been engaged in to push back against the
Chinese virus I want to assure the
American people that as president Trump
just said your State Department your
entire national security team is staying
focused on the other diplomatic
challenges around the world those
include reducing risk to America from
Afghanistan holding the Iranian regime
accountable for its Mayan activity and
our counterterrorism efforts against
Isis remain a priority for our team our
number-one priority across those mission
sets remains the protection of the
American people the president our team
are very focused on it I'll take this mo
to to thank my team State Department
team who's working long hours all around
the world to take care of Americans who
are stuck in place around the world I'll
talk about that more in just a minute
you've all seen dr. Burks with me the
State Department fisher's is doing great
work but I want to I want to give a
shout out to all of the State Department
team here in Washington around the world
that are working overtime to help us
push back against this pandemic under
the president's leadership this week
we've taken two important steps first as
president Trump announced on Wednesday
the United States and Canada jointly
agreed to restrict all non-essential
traffic across our border this decision
goes into effect tonight at midnight the
restrictions will be reviewed after 30
days and they exclude traffic and
movement across the border for work or
other essential reasons we're grateful
to have such an outstanding friend to
the north who is committed as we are to
defeating now calling it the Chinese
buyer I also wanted outs today that the
United States and Mexico have agreed to
restrict non-essential travel across our
shared border both our countries know
the importance of working together to
limit the spread of the virus to ensure
the commerce that supports our economy
continues to keep flowing here to the
United States is glad to have a friend
whose working side by side us in the
fight secretary wolf will talk a little
bit more
or about the details of how we're
working alongside our partner in Mexico
to keep our southern border safe and
secure as well
on another note yesterday the State
Department issued a level 4 global
travel advisory that is unprecedented
this means that all international travel
from US citizens should be avoided in
countries where commercial departure
options remain available u.s. citizens
who reside in the United States should
arrange for immediate return to the
United States unless they're prepared to
remain abroad for an extended time if
you choose to travel international your
travel funds may well be severely
disrupted and finally I want to talk
about the disinformation that people are
seeing both on Twitter around the world
some of it coming from government some
of it coming from other individuals just
urge everyone as they're seeing
information information that at one time
suggested somehow this virus emanated
from the United States Army this
information about lock downs that are
taking place every American indeed
people all around the world should
ensure that where they turn to for
information is a reliable source and not
a bad actor trying to create and flow
information that they know is wrong this
is a tough fight the American people
with tougher our diplomatic teams are
working around the clock to help them
keep safe both home and abroad and we're
showing once again the global leadership
that America has always delivered it's
been great to see countries around the
world well rally behind what President
Trump and our team are doing well let me
start off by thanking the president and
the vice president for their continued
leadership and commitment for protecting
the American people during this crisis
early on the president again took
unprecedented actions to restrict travel
from areas affected with the coronavirus
and to date DHS has screened over
200,000 individuals coming back from
those affected communities not tested
this has have been an immense
undertaking screen1 that the men and
women of DHS have successfully
accomplished today's announcement is yet
another example of the extraordinary
steps the administration is taking to
ensure the safety of the American public
Chad before I comment on the CDC order
that I'm sure secretary azar
later elaborate on let me first address
the progress as secretary Pompeo and
others have made with our Canadian and
Mexican partners regarding cross-border
travel as we continue to evaluate
common-sense measures that reduce risk
and prevent further spread it only makes
sense that we have looked to look at the
measures that our neighbors to the north
and south are undertaking and so we've
been working closely with those partners
since the earliest days of this virus
and the outbreak and again as the
President did said earlier this week in
secretary Pompeo we've reached an
agreement agreement with both Canada and
Mexico to a limit till Lymon
non-essential travel across our land
borders let me be clear that neither of
these agreements with Canada or Mexico
applies to lawful trade or commerce
essential commercial activities will not
be impacted we will continue to maintain
a strong and secure economic supply
chain across our borders a few examples
of a central Travel include but
certainly are not limited to individuals
traveling from medical purposes to
attend educational institutions for
emergency response public health
services and individuals engaged in
lawful cross-border trades as the
secretary said the agreements with both
Canada and Mexico will go into effect on
Saturday March 21st furthermore we're
also working collaboratively with Canada
and Mexico to take decisive a joint
action regarding individuals seeking
entry between our ports of entry the CDC
order directs the Department to suspend
the introduction of all individuals
seeking to enter the u.s. without proper
travel documentation that's for both the
northern and southern border the CDC
director has determined that the
introduction and spread of the corona
virus and the department's border patrol
stations and detention facilities
presents a serious danger to migrants
are frontline agents and officers and
the American people so it's important to
note that the department currently
apprehends foreign nationals from over
120 different countries around the world
the vast majority of those having
coronavirus cases many of these
individuals arrive with little or no
identity travel or medical documentation
making public health risk determinations
all
but impossible it's also too important
to note that the outbreak on our
southern border would likely increase
the strain on health systems in our
border communities taken away important
and life-saving resources from American
citizens tonight again at midnight we
will execute the CDC order by
immediately returning individuals
arriving without documentation to Canada
Mexico as well as a number of other
countries without delay and so again
CBP is positioned to execute these
measures as we continue to keep our
borders secure and safe before I
conclude let me just wrap up by thanking
the brave men and women of DHS
specifically CBP and across the
government for the work that they do day
in and day out to keep the American
people safe from the coronavirus the
department has a number of frontline
officers that have been has tested
positive as well as others who are self
quarantine and that I am doing
everything that I can to protect these
Patriots as they continue to defend our
homeland
during this crisis this is an active
chat today's announcement is just the
latest in a long line of bold decisive
actions the president has taken to
protect Americans from the corona virus
spreading across our borders in January
within two weeks of China's notifying
w-h-o about the virus and with only 45
cases in China we began screening
travelers from Wuhan then over time as
the Africa volved the president
restricted travel from China Iran and
Europe our health experts say that these
measures have been truly effective at
slowing the viruses spread to our shores
just think about this Italy and the
United States both saw their first
travel related case of coronavirus
around the exact same time the last week
of January oh boy and yet we have had
precious time to continue our work
around vaccines therapeutics and other
preparations this is the propaganda
Italy has tragically been overwhelmed
with critical patients for several weeks
now the president today is taking action
to slow the spread of infectious disease
via our border under Section 362 of the
public
Service Act the CDC is suspending the
entry of certain persons into the United
States Catholics like pockets of the
public health threat that their entry
into the United States represents this
order applies to persons coming from
Mexico and Canada who are seeking to
enter the country illegally and who
would normally be held in a congregate
setting like a Customs and Border
Protection station it does not apply to
u.s. citizens or lawful permanent
residents during this pandemic a number
of health challenges arise when illegal
immigrants arrive at our northern and
southern borders and are taken into
immigration custody we're talking about
significant numbers of illegal
immigrants from this past October
through February DHS has processed more
than 21,000 inadmissible aliens at the
northern border and more than 150 1,000
inadmissible aliens at the southern
border
CBP facilities were never designed to
hold large numbers of people and to
protect agents and migrants from
infection during a pandemic treatment
opinions are what we care a novel virus
if large numbers are infected when held
at border facilities these migrants were
spreading the virus to other migrants to
CBP agents and border health care
workers and even the United States
population as a whole
in such circumstances the kind of social
distancing measures the CDC and the
president have recommended are simply
not possible on top of that any
resources that we are using to reduce
the risk of infection among CBP agents
health care workers and migrants in
these facilities are drawing on American
an American health care system that is
already fighting the corona virus
pandemic that's why the president and
his administration are taking these
important steps to keep Americans and
our immigration system safe from these
health risks as part of our whole of
government approach to combating the
corona virus Thank You mr. president for
the work that you've been doing
throughout this crisis to slow the
spread of the corona virus and to keep
our country safe we want to hear from
pouty and Burkes really
mr. president so we continue to review
the data very carefully from around the
globe as I know many of you are we
continue to see signs that again
individuals under 20 19 and under may
have severe disease but majority and all
have recovered to date we still see that
same trend and frankly from Italy we're
seeing a very another concerning trend
that the mortality and mail seems to be
twice in every age group of females this
should alert all of us to continue our
vigilance to protect our Americans that
are in nursing homes this requires all
of the community when you see the
sacrifices that many Americans have made
the sacrifices that the service industry
has made to close their restaurants
close their bars and so that the spread
is discontinued and then you really
understand how all of Americans must
make the same sacrifice we continue to
ask you to follow the presidential
guidelines of no groups coming together
of more than 10 that if anyone in the
household is sick that everyone
quarantines in the household together
and that we continue to focus on those
who have the most vulnerability to this
illness now to the moms and dads out
there that have children with
immunodeficiencies or other medical
conditions we don't know the level of
risk and I know you will also protect
them in the same way there just is not
enough numbers at this time to really
tell them if they're at additional risk
are not in the same way that adults are
I don't have any new data I can see the
look on your face is saying is she
seeing something new I don't have any
new data but I think it's important for
us to be as honest with the American
people as we can and when we don't have
data be very clear that we don't know
finally no one is immune I sometimes
hear people on radio or others talking
about I'm immune to the virus we don't
know if the contagion levels are
difference in age groups but we know
it's highly contagious
everyone do not interpret mild or
moderate disease as lack of contagion or
that you're a mu immune you just happen
to have a better immune system and the
ability to fight the virus in a way that
maybe older people or people with
existing medical conditions can't and
that's why it's very important at this
moment that all of you carry that
message about the sacrifices that many
have made particularly our service
providers and our frontline health care
workers they making that sacrifice every
day so that every American we can move
through this well but we need every
American following the presidential
guidelines thank you thank you very much
I just want to underscore a couple of
things that I said a few times to this
group you may recall that just a week
ago or so I said the two pillars the two
elements of our capability to contain
the infection and the and the surge of
infections in this country rely on two
things keeping infections from coming
from without in we've been very
successful in doing that with China and
with Europe now we have the northern and
southern Borden issues there's a
fundamental public health reason for
doing that because we cannot be
preventing people from coming in from
one area when they can actually go into
the other so that's an important reason
understand that there's a public health
reason for doing that the second thing I
think is really important is what
happened in New York today what Governor
Cuomo mentioned about an hour ago some
rather strong issues that have been
addressed with his recommendations not
recommendations essentially orders now
we have a group of recommendations and
guidelines that are applicable to the
entire country
you know them we've been over them yet
there are places region states cities in
this country that are being stressed
much much more than the country as a
whole
yeah clearly one of them was Washington
another one was California governor
newson made some very important
difficult decisions today Governor Cuomo
did the same thing and
to say I strongly support what he's
doing and one thing as a New Yorker
myself for those of you who haven't
figured out for my accent that I'm from
New York as in New Yorker I know what
New Yorkers can do we're tough I was in
New York City on September 11th 2001 and
I know what the New Yorkers can do so
please cooperate with your governor
cooperate with your mayor it's very
important thank you thank you Thank You
mr. president for your incredible
leadership the White House coronavirus
task force met this morning we continue
at the president's direction to bring
the full resources not just of the
federal government but in full
partnership with our state governments
businesses around America and a
partnership with the American people to
respond to the threat of the coronavirus
and I know I can speak on behalf of the
president with confidence when I say how
inspired we are by the way the American
people and American businesses are
coming together to help defeat this
virus in our country millions of
Americans are putting into practice the
president's 15-day guidelines and we
encourage everyone even those that are
not in areas with significant outbreak
to review these guidelines over the next
week and more and put them into practice
and you'll continue to do your part and
if you order today we'll be talking with
manufacturers around the country and
president I continue to be inspired by
the way American industry is stepping
forward we have businesses around the
country that are literally volunteering
to retrofit plants to help us meet the
needs of our health care workers and our
health care system in confronting the
coronavirus as the president mentioned
yesterday following his decision to put
FEMA in the lead the emergency
declaration we actually met with all the
nation's governors from the FEMA
National Response Coordination Center
the President and I our entire team at
the federal level couldn't be more
grateful for the efforts of all of our
governor's in implementing the guidance
that is being issued not only from our
task force but also
in taking strong measures in their own
communities to protect their citizens we
want to urge every American to heed your
local authorities listen to their
guidance and and also do your part to
slow the spread we reiterated to all of
the governor's that the president by
putting FEMA in the lead will continue
to implement a plan that is locally
executed state managed and federally
supported that puts the health of
America first we received a report today
as president mentioned on our
legislative team on Capitol Hill we're
working with Republicans and Democrats
at this very hour to pass an economic
recovery package that the president
described and we hope to see the
Congress act on that early next week on
the subject of supplies we continue to
make steady progress on testing thanks
to the president's involvement of
commercial labs the public and private
partnership more and more Americans are
being tested every single day and
tomorrow
Admiral Gua and FEMA will update the
American public on the status of testing
and our support of state-based testing
efforts that are literally expanding by
the hour on the subject of medical
supplies we continue at the president's
direction to pursue every means to
expand the supply of personal protective
equipment for the extraordinary and
courageous health care workers that are
ministering to the needs of people
impacted by the coronavirus we have a
policy of procuring allocating as well
as conserving the resources that we have
in our system and now that the president
worked with the Congress to make
industrial masks fully available right
for hospitals to be able to purchase to
be able to use as protective equipment
we're more encouraged than ever
about the availability of those
important in 95 mass to our health care
facilities and over this weekend we'll
be announcing a major procurement from
the federal government n95 masks as well
we're also encouraged that we're finding
new alternatives to increase the supply
of ventilators
we've mentioned that we have a federal
stockpile some 20,000 ventilators on on
standby but that doesn't count the tens
of thousands of ventilators that are in
our healthcare system around the country
to paraphrase pence we need to
drastically accelerate the ability of
people to profit from this virus their
sources around the country and there are
two different ways that we're doing that
number one in our recent discussion with
anesthesiologist we've literally
identified tens of thousands of existing
ventilators that can be retrofitted and
converted to be ventilators for people
struggling with the corona virus but
also on the president's behalf on behalf
of all of our task force we want to
continue to urge every American and
every American hospital and healthcare
facility to postpone any elective
medical procedures this will free up bed
space free up hospital capacity for
people that are struggling with the
corona virus and it'll also free up
equipment that our health care workers
need it is inspiring that we continue to
receive reports that businesses around
America are donating and ninety-five
mass to their local hospitals businesses
large and small or donating hundreds in
some cases millions of n95 mess and I
know I know how grateful the president
is and we all are and let me close by
saying as all of our experts have said
many times while the threat of serious
illness to the average American from the
corona virus remains low every American
can do your part to reduce the burden on
your health on your family the burden on
our healthcare system and especially the
threat to the most vulnerable among us
by putting into practice right the
president's 15 days to slow the spread
and as the president said at the outset
of his remarks I know that millions of
Americans are doing that just now and
the greatness of the American character
is shining forth thanks Mike
okay Thank You Dora you had a call
senator schumer he says you've now
agreed to invoke the defense production
act to actually make those medical
supplies that hospitals say for in
severe shortage so two questions is that
what you're doing now it is I did it
yesterday we invoked it I think the day
before we signed it the evening of the
day before and invoked it yesterday we
have a lot of people working very hard
to do ventilators and various other
things yes using it now to tell business
we are using ventilators mass for
certain things that we need including
including some of the very important
emergency I would say ventilators
probably more masks to a large extent we
have millions of masks invoking strongly
and which will be distributed to the
states the states are having a hard time
getting them so we were using the act
the act is very good for things like
this we have millions of masks that
we've ordered they will be here soon
we're having them shipped directly to
States you were signing this but not
invoking it this is what you said
yesterday and you would only do so in a
worst-case scenario so we never scenario
we we need no it's no different other
than we need certain equipment that the
states are unable to get by themselves
so we're invoking it to use the powers
of the federal government to help the
states get things that they need like
the masks like trumple invoke anything
someone suggests he'll invoke brown vert
the Board of Education if he thinks
it'll be useful politically iteration to
a national lockdown the key people no I
don't think so essentially you've done
that in California you've done that in
New York those are really two hot beds
as it probably the two hottest of them
all in terms of hot spots hi I don't
think so because you go out to the
Midwest you go out to other locations
and they're watching it on television
but they don't have the same problems my
wife by and by any means the same
problem New York California Miami the
governor is doing an excellent job
governor DeSantis in Florida we have
some pretty hot spots in Florida too but
we're a general and the state of
Washington of course but that was
largely if you look at it it was one
nursing home that had
problems like you wouldn't believe so
now we're working with the governor's
and I don't think you'll I don't think
we'll ever find that no system a week
gives you 50 day guidelines are you
happy with the progress would you like
to see I am happy I am happy with it
we'll have to see what the results are
at the end of 14 days let's say well
know by the 15th day to see what we do
but I'm certainly honored by the way the
American people are working because it's
work it's work not to work this is the
first time this has ever happened and
we're working out a tremendous financial
package for them when you're not working
work out tough who ever heard of this
usually you work out a financial package
to get people working we're asking
people not to work the social distancing
that new term that's become probably the
hottest term there is so no I'm very
honored by the way the American people
are taking this image so seriously yes
Jenna a question for you in a question
for dr. faster if I could there's been
some concern among Democrats on Capitol
Hill that the phase three fiscal
stimulus is weighted too much in favor
of corporations and not enough in terms
of individuals well yeah what did your
conversations with Senator Schumer yield
on that for well I think that really all
of that is being discussed right now and
we talked about as an example buy back
stock buybacks I don't want to have
stock buybacks I don't want people
spending I don't want some executives
saying we're gonna buy 200,000 shares of
stock I want that money to be is for the
workers and also for the company to keep
the company going but not for buybacks I
would I mean I haven't spoken to a lot
of the Republicans or Democrats owner we
discussed it and I I don't like buybacks
I didn't like him the first time senator
Schumer's interesting we're discussing
that with discussing many things on the
same page from Senator Kyle we're not so
far away I'll tell you what not very
we're not very far away and to dr.
Bacchi if I could dr. Kashi as was
explained yesterday there has been some
promise with hydroxychloroquine this
potential therapy for people who are
infected with
the virus is there any evidence to
suggest that as with malaria it might be
used as a prophylaxis against Cobra 19
no the answer is is no and and the the
evidence that you're talking about John
is anecdotal evidence so as the
Commissioner of FDA and the president
mentioned yesterday we're trying to
strike a balance between making
something with a potential of an of an
effect to the American people available
at the same time that we do it under the
auspices of a protocol that would give
us information to determine if it's
truly safe and truly effective but the
information that you're referring to
specifically is anecdotal it was not
done in the control of clinical trial so
you really can't make any definitive
statement about it without seeing too
much I'm probably more of a fan of that
then maybe than anybody but I'm a big
fan we'll see what happens and we will
understand it with Florrick when the
doctor said is 100% correct it's early
but we've you know I've seen things that
are impressive and we'll see we're gonna
know soon we're gonna know soon in
including safety but you know when you
get that safety this has been prescribed
for many years for people to combat
malaria which was a big problem and it's
very effective it's a strong it's a
strong drug so what's wrong they're
against disarms it was very it was as I
understand that I is that a correct
statement it was fairly effective when
SARS John you've got to be careful when
you say fairly effective it was never
done in the clinical trial they compared
it to anything it was given to
individuals and felt that maybe it works
Avery
it's a parrot - yeah well that's the
point whenever you do a clinical trial
you do standard of care versus standard
of care plus the agent you're evaluating
that's the reason why we showed back in
Ebola why particular interventions
worked
now she's right about the possible
therapies yesterday
mr. president you said that they were
for quote immediate delivery of media we
heard over lottery yes we have millions
of units ordered units a bear is one of
the companies as you know big company
very big very great company millions of
units are ordered and we're going to see
what happens we're going to be talking
to the governor's about it and the FDA
is working on it right now
the advantage is that it has been
prescribed for a totally different
problem but it has been described for
many years and everybody knows the
levels of the negatives and the
positives but I will say that I am a man
that comes from a very positive school
when it comes to in particular one of
these drugs and we'll see how it works
out Peter I've not found it but I
usually draw that people may be
surprised by the way there would be a
game-changer but we're going to know
very soon but but we have ordered
millions of units it's being ordered but
from Bayer and there is another a couple
of companies also that that do it to say
there is no magic drug for coronavirus
right now which you would agree I guess
on this issue I think we only is this my
limited sorry
maybe and maybe not maybe it'd be really
and we have to say to each other
is it possible is it possible that your
impulse to put a positive spin on things
maybe giving Americans a false sense no
I don't think so
okay so I think that I think it's got
you know not yet a pretty strong look it
may work and it may not work and I agree
with the doctor what he said may work
may not work I feel good about it that's
all it is just a feeling um smart guy
yeah I feel good about you know about
medical we're gonna see you're gonna see
soon enough and we have certainly some
very big samples of people have you look
at the people oh you have a lot of
people that are in big trouble
thirty people and this is not a drug
that obviously I think I can speak for a
lot of it from a lot of experience
because it's been out there for over 20
years so really not you you're more a
danger with it's not like a brand new
drug that's been just created that it
may have an unbelievable monumental
effect like kill you
we're gonna know very soon and I can
tell you the FDA is working very hard to
get it out right now in terms of malaria
if you wanted you can have a
prescription you get a prescription and
by the way and it's very effective it
works I have a feeling you may and I'm
not being overly optimistic or
pessimistic I sure as hell think we
ought to give it a try I mean there's
been some interesting things happened
and some good very good things let's see
what happens we have nothing to lose you
know the expression what the hell do you
have to lose scared though I guess
you'll be 200 dead 14,000 you're sick
millions as you witness who are scared
right now what do you say to Americans
we're watching you right now you're
scared I say that you're a terrible
reporter that's what I say wow I think
it's a very nasty question nasty and I
think it's a very bad signal that you're
putting out to the American people the
American people are looking for answers
and they're looking Wow
and you're doing sensationalism and well
same with NBC and Comcast I don't call
it I don't call it Comcast I call it
Comcast let me just have you work let me
just say something that's really bad
reported nothing you want to get back to
report a good set of sensationalism
let's see if it works it might and it
might
Wow I happened to feel good about it
trauma trios I've been write a lot let's
see what happens junk go back to the
science from the logistics the units
that were ordered are they for clinical
trials are they for distribution to the
general patient population we are going
to as I understand it we are going to be
taking samples in New York Governor
Cuomo very much is interested in this
drug and they are going to work on it
also after they get a certain approval
we're waiting for one final approval
from the FDA we'll see what happens but
we'll use it on people that are not
doing great or even at the beginning of
not feeling learned fallen under than
John what do we have to lose he's
yelling at every way John it's been out
there for so long we hear good things
let's see maybe it works it maybe it
does you got to get him off you just
think a meltdown case you hear so that
would be under sort of a modified
compassionate access we're doing that I
guess and that's that's what it's called
you know what the president is saying
should Americans have hope in this drug
right now and sir I would like to follow
up on Peters question here could you
please issue address Americans in this
country who are scared right now this is
a very valid concern that people have
know there really isn't that much of a
difference in many respects with what we
say the president feels optimistic about
something his feeling about it what I'm
saying is that it might it might be
effective I'm not saying that it isn't
it might be effective but as a scientist
as we're getting it out there we need to
do it in a way as while we are making it
available for people who might want the
hope that it might work you're also
collecting data that data ultimately
show that it is truly effective and safe
under the conditions of covert 19 so
there really isn't different it's just a
question of how one feels about it well
certainly as a drug any drug John has
some toxicities the decades of
experience that we have with this drug
indicate that the toxicities are rare
and they are in many respects reversible
what we don't know is when you put it in
the context of another disease
whether it's safe fundamentally I think
it probably is gonna be safe but I like
to prove things first so it really is a
question of not a lot of difference it's
the hope that will work versus proving
that it will work so I don't see big
differences here don't they need to do
their job my message to the American
people is that there is a very low
incidence of death you understand that
and we're gonna come through this
stronger than ever before if you get it
if you happen to get it it is highly
unlikely it's looking like it's getting
to a number that's much smaller than
people originally thought in terms of
the ultimate the ultimate problem which
would be death my message to the
American people is number one you've
done an incredible job
incredible what you've gone through it's
been an craite wasn't their fault wasn't
their fault it wasn't the fault of a
hundred and forty other countries where
this has happened and there is
tremendous hope and I think you're gonna
come out stronger better bigger in every
way I think we're gonna be a better
country than we were before we learned a
lot we learned on reliance but we let my
contact early on but our country our
country has been incredible the way they
pull together including the fact that I
just spoke to Senator Schumer we had a
wonderful conversation we both want to
get to a good solution but it's been it
really for me watching and seeing people
that weren't speaking getting along well
because we all have one common aim and
that's to get rid of this invisible
enemy get rid of it fast the skin and go
back to the kind of economy that we had
and maybe even better yeah please do
just OAM no the back the first button is
named small business concerning that
they have weeks not once I don't worry
about how long it'll take this is we're
gonna be helping them a lot would it be
focused a big focus on spices they're my
conversation with both what John Spicer
is asking questions love okay for that
conversation with small businesses
because they are really the engine
working more so than the big ones they
are the engine behind our country are
you concerned about members of Congress
that may have used information they
learned on updates to sell stocks and
profit office I'm not aware of it I saw
some names I'm not on I know all of them
I know everyone mentioned dianne
feinstein i guess and and a couple of
others i do all other remote yeah what
it's about but i find them to all be
very honorable people that's all I know
they and they said they did nothing
wrong I find them the whole group very
honorable people yeah please
what does John Spicer doing there the
whole group would include Richard Burr
the head of the Intelligence Committee
and it also would include senator Kelly
Lafleur right and so Republican is
whether or not they should be
investigated for that behavior well it
also includes Dianne Feinstein a
Democrat yeah you mentioned her name why
didn't you mention her name
cuz he'd and I think she's a very
honorable person by the way so I'm not
saying but you know it's interesting
that you mentioned two people but you
don't mention one that happens to be at
them well you only main competitor
should I don't know because I'd have to
look at it but possibly but I find them
to be honorable people oh my god
you see yourself as a wartime president
right now leading the country through
this pandemic that were experiencing do
you really think you know going off on
Peter going off on a network as
appropriate
yeah country's going through something
like I do I think Peter is you know I
dealt with Peter for a long time and I
think Peter is not a good journalist
when it comes to fairness Wow oh I think
it's good message because I think that
the country has to understand that there
is indeed whether we like it or not and
some of the people in this room won't
like it there's a lot of really great
news and great journalism and there's a
lot of fake news out there oh my god
and I hear it all and I see it all and I
understand it all because I'm in the
midst of it so when somebody writes a
story if there's a story on television
and I know it's false I know it's fake
and when they say they have 50,000 I
know there's no sources there's no
sources they just make it it up I know
that and I call Peter I call Peter out
but I call other people out too and you
know this is time to come together but
coming together is more questions on
John Spicer when we have dishonest
journalists it's a very important
profession that you're in it's a
profession that I think is incredible I
cherish it but when people are dishonest
they truly do hurt our country yeah in
the back please go ahead
education with the United States and
also wh the u.s. sheriff in order to
travelers from China is a February the
second also has been in lockdown since
January the 24th and this all happened
almost two months ago I deduce Tuesday
if if you could have known it earlier
beautiful question and also you have
been calling I have to say this we have
and I can speak for myself but I have a
very good relationship with China and
with President Xi I have great respect
for President Xi I can tell him to be a
friend of mine it's unfortunate that
this got out of control it came from
China got out of control
some people are upset I know I know
President Xi I
he loves China I respects the United Sun
gun friend I have to say I respect China
greatly and I respect President Xi
in stock buybacks is a deal breaker for
you this no but I never liked stock
buybacks from their standpoint when we
did a big tax cut and when they took the
money and did buybacks
that's not building a hangar that's not
buying aircraft that's not doing the
kind of things that I want them to do
and we're now talking about buybacks we
didn't think we would have had to
restrict it because we thought they
would have known better they didn't know
better in some kid not in all cases
obviously some people did an incredible
job they didn't realize that we paid the
money to vote both of their own see
what's happened I mean we were doing
until this invisible enemy appeared what
an implosion we were I mean we never had
an economy like this but there were some
companies that use that money to buy
back stock driving up the price of the
stock artificially in many cases I don't
like that I don't like it God is worried
about whether or not we'll have that
allow them when we give them money
because we have to keep these great
companies in business what because of
the workers frankly for the most part
because of the workers the workers are
my number one concern but the way we
take care of the workers is we have to
keep the companies going I am fine with
restricting buybacks in fact I would I
would demand that there be no stock
buybacks I don't want them taking
hundreds of millions of dollars and
buying back their stock because that
does nothing yeah please
[Music]
and one thing Secretary of State Bob
Mayo is extremely busy so if you have
any question for him right now could you
do that because you know what I'd like
to do I'd like to him to go back to the
State Department or as they call it the
deep State Department you don't mind Oh
have him go back and do his job so does
anybody have any questions on work
travel can you define that this all
worked with anyone with a work visa can
still cross the border can you define
yeah it's a measure to your taking it's
a great question
well we're working we were very good
real concern about h-2a visas
particularly how to sleeping that need
to get across we're gonna make sure that
we do everything we can to keep that
part of our economic lifeblood working
between our two countries DHS and the
State Department will work together we
want to make sure and keep commerce
between Canada the United States and
Mexico alive functional and prepared for
the day that this economy bounces back
like we expected it will the Mexican
government has not announced any travel
ban on Europe word have you Benny talked
with them as to when they're gonna do
this and what it is that they're telling
you and then a second question they also
are telling us and said in a press
conference this morning that they will
not take back any non Mexican citizen
any other third parties who have - we
don't know what will happen to them so
can you address what will happen to
those third country immigrants that you
are
that will not be allowed to enter the US
and Mexico saying that they will not be
allowed to stay in Mexico either or sent
back from the US I'll take the first one
in chat I'll give you the second one
with respect to travel into Mexico from
my side I spoke with foreign minister
abroad a couple of times about this I'm
very confident we're gonna get to a
really good place that protects the
Mexican people and the American people
from those who might be travelling into
places where we've got designations the
Schengen zone from China so that they're
not coming into Mexico and then coming
into the United States I'm very
confident we'll do that we'll make that
announcement shortly together as we
implement the cdc's order again we're
gonna take a number of individuals that
cross the border illegally and
repatriate them and remove them quickly
back to Mexico back to the northern
triangle and back to any other country
so we're gonna do that in a rapid
fashion we'll continue to work with
Mexico to make sure that Mexican
nationals go back as well as other
populations Sandeen what a mile
inspector what a mile of Cubans back to
Cuba what would you do those third
countries that are not Mexicans so we're
doing all of the above we're gonna be
sending it again individuals back to
Mexico individuals back to the northern
triangle countries Cuba Haiti all these
in the calendar 22 different nations
that we see - analogies that come across
that border we'll be sending them back
individually to their countries but also
with working with Mexico to send
additional populations back there as
well you know when you said before you
said they're non Mexicans going to
Mexico we're not sending them to Mexico
we're sending them back to their own
countries not to make so why would
Mexico take people that are from X's
right we're sending them back in the
case of Guatemala Honduras El Salvador a
lot of other countries they get back to
the country for there's many more
countries on the issue of disinformation
is there any particular locus for this
disinformation or is it it's pretty
diffused unfortunately nasty but we've
certainly seen it come from places like
China and Russia and Iran where there
are coordinated efforts to disparage
what America is doing in an activity to
have to do all the things that President
Trump has set in motion here right then
what you're doing this morning what are
you doing to fight
things lots of work one of the things
one make sure is the American people go
to trusted sources for the information
but we've made clear we've spoken to
these countries directly that we don't
that they need to knock it off that we
don't approve of it knocking our handful
of other things were engaged in to make
sure that the right information is out
there and accurate information is given
this busting of transparency and
accurate information is very important
how we protect American people from
something like this ever happening again
undermine you at all when the president
stands up here and the attacks news
outlets calling us untrustworthy sort of
Peace Corps military kids who find
themselves stranded in places where
there are no longer flights to get back
to the United States what efforts are
being made to help them I appreciate
that question so we're doing lots of
things we've had a couple places in
particular Peru and Morocco I think
we've had the first two maybe three now
flights out of Morocco what we're gonna
work to get people back we're urging
individuals when they can't get back on
their own they traveled they're on their
own when they can get back they're on
their own they ought to try it to do
that right but we are we have a team
stood up at the State Department the
repatriation task force that is working
each of these instances so we've heard
from individuals members of Congress
we're trying to get Americans back from
these places where air travel has been
disrupted now and we will get that done
over time we'll get it done successfully
we don't know the full scale of it yet
but we think we have the largest number
identified and we're working if there
are those who are watching that are
someplace and you can get up you can go
on the State Department website you can
log in to get step gov and go step and
someone will we'll track in we'll try to
get everybody back - how long are these
border restrictions likely to last
thirty days are long or before
well they'll last as long as we need to
do it to protect the American people
from the price I couldn't tell you how
long it's gonna last
we have you have you determined whether
Iran is responsible for that rocket
attack last week so maybe we should say
so let me just let me just get back to
you on the answer to that and what we
could what we know what we can say what
we can say with certainty is as we've
made clear all along that the Iraqi Shia
militias are funded trained equipped by
the Iranians and we've urged the Iranian
ah'd to do that and we've told the
Iranians that they will be held
responsible for those attacks when they
threaten American lives the Peace Corps
volunteers that are in 60-plus countries
that they all been returned you know I
don't know if they're all back or not
yet I know that they were directed to
come back I know that most of them
Rebecca I couldn't tell you if we have
all of them back in the secretary Gasper
is not here but to get tests to the
troops in Iraq and Afghanistan are you
able to give us a progress report on the
status of that if they're already able
to get tests I don't know the answer to
that I know we have State Department
officials to who are concerned want to
make sure we get them tests our team as
well and we're working on that we've had
I rather don't know that to date there
are a few places in life been able to
get them but we will we'll get them
there how exactly are you gonna get
those Americans back and do you have any
plans to get the military involved in
that we're gonna use all the tools we
can these first efforts are combined
commercial private flights that will fly
in bring them back bring them back to a
destination here in the United States so
we'll do that there are some that'll
travel back other ways as well
and we've worked with the Department of
Defense to say where there are a space
available we'll be able to bring them
back on those flights as well it's the
old government effort to make sure we
get them back home again they're gonna
help us every place they can this is
just crazy I mean Iran again
relax some sanctions on Iran during the
course that's a question the whole world
should know that humanitarian assistance
into Iran is wide open it's not
sanctioned we offered to provide
assistance to the Iranians as well I
talked with dr. Ted Rose from the World
Health Organization about this we're
doing everything we can to facilitate
both the humanitarian assistance moving
in and to make sure the financial
transactions connect to that can take
place as well
there is no sanction on medicines going
to run there's no sanctions on
humanitarian assistance going into the
country they've got a terrible problem
there and we want that humanitarian
medical healthcare assistance to get to
the people of Iran sanctions themselves
we are working to do all the things
we've had in place for the first three
years here to deliver security for the
American people the leaders they know
the answer to your question the
president for three years now I know how
much he values the people that work on
my team I know when I was the director
of the selkies agency how much he valued
the work we did I know that he watches
our team dr. Burks all the team that's
working to push back against this virus
to keep America safe I know how much he
values them I know mama
the CDC picked up but there was some
sort of virus happening in will on the
karana fires happening any new hub as
early as December 1 did the CDC start
letting other agencies know that there
was something in China Gooden was
coronavirus was happening and then when
did the whole government approach pop
sir to happen so I'll let the CDC please
yeah yeah so so we had her lie about the
by some discussions that dr. Redfield
the director of the CDC had with Chinese
colleagues on January 3rd it's since
been known that there may have been
cases in December not that we were
alerted in December there's been some
discussion about China and what they
knew and when they knew it and I've been
very critical we need to know
immediately the world is entitled to
know the Chinese government to know of
this risk to the world and that puts a
special obligation to make sure that
data that against our scientists are
professionals heinous it's not about
retribution this matters going forward
we're know we're in a live exercise here
to get this right we we need to make
sure that even today the datasets that
are available to every country including
datasets that are available to the
Chinese Communist Party are made
available to the Chinese Communist it's
an imperative to keep people safe we
talked about the absence of datasets not
being able to make judgments about what
to do this is absolutely this
transparency this real-time information
sharing isn't is it about political
games or retribution it's about keeping
people safe and so when you see a delay
in information flowing from the Chinese
Communist Party to the technical people
who we wanted to get into China
immediately to assist in this every
moment of delay connected to being able
to identify this risk vector the risk
vectors creates risk to the people all
around the world and so this is why it's
not about blaming someone for this this
is about moving forward to make sure
that we continue to have the information
we need to do our jobs secretary what
what message do you think it sends to
other countries when you have the
present United States lashing out at
reporters I've had my frustration with
reporters to media is that you listen to
what we say and report it accurately and
it's frustrating it's frustrating when
you see what you see what you see that
doesn't happen is its enormous ly
frustrating we have a responsibility to
tell the American people the truth and
those who are reporting on what it is
we're doing and saying have an equal
responsibility to report accurately I've
seen I've seen many things at the State
Department reported wildly and
accurately on multiple occasions and I
have spoken to those reporters about it
each and every time and I will continue
to do so I think all right mr. secretary
senator Johnson has suggested that you
and the administration may be
overreacting he said we don't shut down
our economy because tens of thousands of
people die on the highways we don't shut
down our economies because tens of
thousands of people die from the common
flu at worst three point four percent of
Americans will die from this virus he
said
you say people that have that view
that's 11 million people he's talking
about well I just say the entire world
is agreeing with us because they're all
they all have their choice and
everybody's doing the exact same thing
we want to shut it out and we can do
that and we'll see what happens in two
weeks and three weeks but if we can save
thousands of lives and even millions of
lives potentially you don't know where
it goes but you could be talking about
millions of lives so if you look at the
the world I mean you have some very
smart people in the world you have some
smart leaders in the world and
everybody's doing it the way we're doing
it I think we're doing a better job then
hopefully most if not all do a very
effective job but we'll we'll know
better in 14 or 15 days but you know and
maybe more than that numbers of people
and you know we can bring our finances
back very quickly we can't bring the
people back there are millions of people
out there that share that view that say
I don't really need to shut things down
I don't really need to stay away from
the stores I don't I can go to the beach
and those people making multiple actions
exponentially it's the difference
between life and death
I agree with it but I think I'd like to
have Anthony answer that because to be
honest that's what he does and he we had
a lot of a lot of very talented people
telling us what they think we should do
Thank You mr. president first of all I
think that's a false equivalency to
compare traffic accidents with I mean
that's totally way out that's really a
false equivalency when you have
something that is new and it's emerging
and you really can't predict totally the
impact it's gonna have and you take a
look at what's gone on in China and you
see what's going on right now right now
in Italy and what's happening in New
York City I don't think with any moral
conscience you could say why don't we
just let it rip and happen and let the X
percent of the people die is right I
don't understand that reasoning at all
okay so Secretary of State will be
leaving any other questions right in the
back place in the back for my president
two things in New York this is a
doubling every day they fear that
supplies are going to run out in a
matter of weeks yesterday
Mayor Bill de Blasio called on you to
mobilize the military to live an urgent
supplies yesterday he said quote the
fate of New York City rests in the hands
of one man he is a New Yorker and right
now he is the Train the city he comes
from
I've personally spoken to emergency
department nurses who say that they're
being told not to wear and ninety five
mosques because supplies are so low so
how do you respond to those remarks by
mayor de Blasio supplies thrive I'm not
dealing with a member dealing with the
governor and the governor agrees with me
and I agree with him so far we've been
very much in sync I I guess they're not
agreeing with each other necessarily but
the relationship with New York I Love
New York I grew up in New York as you
probably have heard and the
relationships have been very good and I
think government and the governor have
been getting on incredibly well with the
federal government okay all right
mr. secretary welcome I could just on on
illegal entries of people who are otm
how will the turn back process work will
they be taken to a common area and then
put on a plane and sit back soon
northern countries or others I mean how
would that process work question pretty
much it's a public health crisis so what
we're trying to do is limit the the
amount of contact that we have with
these individuals not putting them in
Border Patrol facilities ice detention
facilities and like so it's gonna be
very rapid we're gonna obviously take
them into custody and then and then send
them back to a port of entry or other
means so it'll be very quickly very
strong to six or seven or ten days that
we currently have it will be much more
rapid TM will you believe you take you
to it and your field that's correct to
Americans the bill is proposed creates
sort of tiers of checks Franco I believe
philosophically that we're working well
believe in a lot of things I want to get
workers money and whichever way the best
way to get it and I want to keep the
businesses open too because without the
businesses they're not gonna be telling
business law close we're gonna be we're
gonna be tough to threaten if they're
not for your business we'll do something
later I'm sure
Wall Street analysts are predicting the
unemployment numbers could skyrocket
next week by some analysts say as many
as 3 million people applying for
unemployment which would be a historic
number of one week spread so he's a
thousand dollar check going to cut it a
second we're not talking about a
thousand dollar check we're talking
about much more than that we're also
talking about doing phases if this
doesn't work we're gonna keep doing
until we get it going and frankly when
money Madonna me a week one source enemy
is defeated the invisible enemies I call
it once it's defeated we get the economy
back it's gonna all come back to us very
quickly it comes to back very quote we
have a tremendous economy we do numbers
like no other country has ever done
before number one in the world they go
back to weeks and still obviously but if
you go back to week's number one of the
world by far that money comes back to us
very rapidly we want to keep it we want
to have one so that when we're not if
but when we win the war yeah with the
invisible enemy when we win it these
companies can immediately start not that
they have to start rebuilding which
takes a long time Steve connections for
job losses in March and April are you
hearing well we're looking at different
numbers we have a best-case in a not
best case but the big thing is to defeat
the virus once that virus is defeated
Steve I think everything else falls in
place very rare gonna be bad I think
you're gonna have a tremendous upswing a
lot of people agree with me a lot of if
you look at your stock market geniuses
and some of whom are not geniuses they
think they are a lot of people think
that I'm right about that once we defeat
the why would we listen to virus I think
you're going to have a very steep like a
rocket ship it's going to go up and
everything will be back and I really
believe we're gonna be stronger than
ever before yeah go ahead
on the issue of supplies you pull
governor's to try to find whatever
supplies they had on their own but some
of them are now saying when they go to
try to buy them they're making out by
the federal government well you heard my
news conference yesterday sort of
yesterday's news no well that does
happen because they want to buy supplies
we want to buy as a backup to them in
case they can and sometimes that will
happen but regardless of who gets them
when they need them we're getting them
to them now we're doing the production
act we're doing it very much and we have
a lot of things cooking right now at a
high level
remember this nothing like this has ever
happened before over a hundred and forty
countries and you have supply chains
that are broken down for two reasons
because they can't supply that much and
because people are sick and they can't
be on the chain so you have a lot of
interesting things all over the world
you have supply chains that broke down
on the cause of the illness and also
because of the fact that the quantity
things are off but we're getting it
ordered we're getting it done and the
rig if you just have to look some of you
were at the call yesterday where I spoke
with the governor's almost all of the
governor's and every one of them was
very impressed with what we've done not
to disclose their unemployment numbers
do you agree with that this gonna have
to talk to I would have to talk to the
DP I just want to be clear are you
saying that the administration is
requiring these industries to create
these products or just asking so far we
haven't had to it's an amazing thing
that happened we're getting calls from
automobile companies we're getting calls
from other companies they have plant
capacity they want to make ventilators
they want to make other things we are
literally being besieged in a beautiful
way they want to do the work they want
to do the job they want to help us they
want to help our country so we haven't
had a problem with that at all
you helped out states and localities
that are trying to bid on things like
ventilators and other items that are
being outfitted by them but when they
call us they let us know if there's a
conflict they will call us and we will
drop our bid because we want them to go
first
because their point the point of sale so
we've had four or five instances where
literally that was happening because you
know we're both trying to get stuck and
if we're going against they will call us
the smart ones frankly will call us and
we will immediately we want them to buy
it because it gets to them quicker if
they buy it they know they're really
there they know that and it's happening
more and more where they're calling and
they say we're bidding against each
other they want to get it they'll get it
much quicker that way there are across
the country that don't have the testing
supplies they need what specific actions
absolutely deal and we've made a good
thing out of it I haven't heard that
question well but go ahead yeah so so
first in we're making tremendous
progress in terms of lab testing tens of
thousands of tests are being done every
single day both through the CDC and the
public health labs as well as now
through the private sector commercial
labs they're getting to scale they have
supplies they have high throughput we do
hear anecdotally occasionally of say a
public health lab or another one that
has a concern about this supply or that
supply through FEMA we actually are
standing up a laboratory task force to
answer those questions usually it's that
the lab people do not understand that
there are actually alternative supplies
in the marketplace that they are
perfectly free to use we've actually had
to put out some common myths and truths
about that for instance the other day we
were getting calls from governors saying
we don't have swabs there no swabs there
are no swabs our supply people went in
the open marketplace and bought 200,000
swabs in the open market and I just sent
a letter to every governor sending them
swabs so
LOB's they aren't listening or checking
with us about all the freedom all the
capacities out there it's a complex
system with 330 million Americans and
all of these labs and so sometimes
there's a lab that doesn't understand
how much flexibility they have and how
much supply there is out there and we're
working through the new FEMA integration
Center you're an NBA player you can get
a test just immediately please wrap with
sombreros as I said more and more tests
are being performed every day and as we
learn about the results that are being
reported around the country of
coronavirus tests our experts continue
to look at the numbers and see that some
90% of Americans that are tested do not
test positive for the corona virus and
so it can give you a sense of the
magnitude of testing that's going on we
in the number of cases that we've
reported today but it's it's in some
cases near to ten times that that have
been tested but let me also emphasize
how important it was in answering these
questions for governors and local
officials that the president stood up
FEMA and the National Response Center
where did a map brief governor's
yesterday now every governor and their
State Department state health
departments have the ability to reach
out with to our regional FEMA
administrators and that's how as the
president said we're sorting out those
potential conflicts between very
significant federal purchases and
procurements and and as hospitals and
state governments are purchasing as well
I think the new streamlined system
operating now in all 50 states and our
territories of Governors and states
going through their Regional
Administrator for FEMA is going to make
it more possible for us to ensure that
our hospitals our health care providers
have access to what's available on the
open market and elsewhere
the head of the task force you've seen
the numbers you've spoken average
Americans or a former governor what do
you say to Americans right now we're
watching and we're scared I would say do
not be afraid be vigilant all the
experts tell us okay that the risk of
serious illness to the average American
for the coronavirus is low but we need
every American to put into practice the
president's coronavirus guidelines 15
days to slow the spread because the
coronavirus is about three times more
contagious than the flu according to our
best estimate and you can contract the
coronavirus have very mild symptoms if
any not even be aware that you have it
and expose someone who is vulnerable to
a very serious health outcome right
that's the reason why we're encouraging
people to avoid groups of more than 10
to not eat in restaurants but to use
drive-throughs to wash their hands on a
regular basis and particularly we're
going to continue as the president has
directed us to focus on the most
vulnerable population which are seniors
with serious underlying health
conditions or anyone with an underlining
immunodeficiency it's those people we
need to care for but it's going to take
all of us working together to make sure
they're safe you just said that you
haven't had to require companies to up
their production of medical supplies but
you've said last night you as both h-tpa
when we need something we'll need some
thin coherence of the act when we need
something we order something and as you
know two days ago why don't people
understand he invoked the Act but didn't
enable it and then did invoke it but
only as a suggestion not as an order why
can't people understand that before we
even go out many many companies great
companies companies in a totally
different business are willing to do
things and make things because that's
what they do they make product they're
willing to make product for us medical
product that we need very badly for the
states that the states can't get they
have a minute
again and you know most of the states in
no way did they do anything wrong they
were stocked up they were all equipped
unfortunately they've never had a thing
like this so they need help from the
federal government you haven't actually
directed any companies to start making
more ventilators or masks and then make
it a lot of ventilators and they make it
a lot of New England admit mr. prisons
partially following up on that are there
automakers right now or retooling their
production facilities mentally ters or I
can't say they are but they will be very
shortly because we're working with one
in particular that wants to make
ventilators they called us yesterday and
they're already we're working on a
transaction they're gonna make
ventilators they say I've done it before
which surprised me but they can do it
very easily secretary Hayes are you said
yesterday that you've spoken to Carnival
corporation's chairman yes and he said
that he could donate some shoes that's
still night that's not like you use them
I spoke with Micky Arison who was the
president chairman CEO and owner he said
he said to me that he was willing to if
we need ships if we need ships for
helping people that carnival would be
absolutely willing to help us in Los
Angeles in New York wherever they may be
in Miami where they're very big if we
needed something that would be willing
to so far we haven't needed to and we're
bringing the big hospital ships up in
California we haven't we're working with
the governor of California's you know
with Gavin and we haven't made a
determination we're also talking the
folks would like it in Seattle so we're
we're discussing where it can be most
useful we've spoken with Governor Cuomo
and we're bringing the big hospital ship
up in two weeks and we're gonna have it
in New York Harbor some place in New
Yorker
so my question is no you didn't run a
casino I've been taking them up on you
yet then I have to impose and if we did
it I'll let you know okay that's cool
taken up secondly right now we don't
need it ships have a lot of frequently
contacted surfaces and so this is where
you come in secretaries are potentially
dr. pouchy you have concerns about those
youth worships being uses hospitals well
I can tell you they're very clean and
also those surfaces the Germans you know
the virus disappears over a period of
time the German ships are very clean
they've been kept very clean they've
been gone over but the virus as you know
of it's on a surface for a certain they
have actually charts different kinds of
surfaces
it disappears over a period of time so
tell us I mean is what are you trying to
get it appears the the virus disappears
when it's on surface after a certain
number of days where that places our
whole pending on the surface can you
stick you name any of the companies that
you've asked to start making these
ventilators oh thanks I will be but
first I want to get the approval from
the company because I don't want to be
doing that well I assume they'd like it
but I'll let you know they would love it
well they can this is for dr. Falchi I
mean one company that has openly stated
it is General Motors I didn't I didn't
speak to them about announcing it but
I'll announce that I'm sure they
wouldn't be but we have others also and
so forth doctor pouchy there's new
research out from that the CDC
release that many of the people that
have or that 13% of the people with the
coronavirus got it from someone that was
asymptomatic Kirk and a question is does
that change the way the approach that
should be taken and do you think that's
the case or the recommendations that are
here applies to whether you're in
physical contact with someone who could
be infected with symptoms versus
asymptomatic I don't really think it
changes anything certainly there is some
degree of asymptomatic transmissibility
it's still not quite clear exactly what
that is but when people focus on that I
think they take their eye off the real
ball which is the things you do will
mitigate against getting infected no
matter whether you're near someone who
is asymptomatic or not it's the same
thing physical separation and the care
that's outlined here is gonna take care
of both of those things
when will every American who needs a
test can attest be able to get a test
good why not have medical equipment
being shipped right now you're hearing
very positive things about testing and
just so you understand we don't want
every American to go out and get a test
three hundred fifty million people we
don't want that we wouldn't yet if we
had a suicide body then haven't wanna
test a lot of good have a problem with
they they're sneezing their sniffling
they don't feel good they have a
temperature there are a lot of different
things you know you know I'm better than
I do so ready we don't need that but
what we are having is we're having these
private labs have come and they've been
really fantastic and we also have a
great system for the future because as I
said we inherited we meaning this
administration an obsolete broken system
Obama wasn't meant for anything like
this now we have a system that you can
see because look we're well into this
and nobody is even talking about it
except for you which doesn't surprise
symptoms and they can't get everybody to
go out and get a test because there's no
reason for it yeah now suggesting that
their real way to get to the end of this
for life to return to normal because
every single person living in this
country to be tested that way you can
see who's contagious and you can then
have people who don't have it go back
into work is there any possibility that
this country could ever get to a point
where every single person could be
tested and how long would that take it's
10 years thank you for the question I've
heard that before
I don't see I don't connect the dots
there I don't see how testing everybody
in the country is gonna help you to
implement this this should be
implemented universally at least at this
level for everyone the things we spoke
about a while ago that you want to
really ratchet it up like your governor
Newsom is doing in California like
Governor Cuomo is doing in New York or
how you put an end to this outbreak
testing is important it would be nice to
know and there are certain things you
could do but let's not conflate testing
with the action that we have to take
whether or not you test do this I'm not
I'm not putting down testing as an
important issue but people seem to link
them so much that if you don't have
universal testing you can't respond to
the outbreak you really can but I do
think and that's after listening to Tony
and everybody else that's an expert I do
think it's important that not everybody
be tested if you feel great and if you
have no symptoms whatsoever it's it's a
it's just not a good thing to be doing
right Steve he's not an explanation
about that about you yesterday you
mentioned the possibility of aerosol
transmission
how likely is that to happen me that oh
the possibility of aerosol transmission
always comes up when you have situations
like that it comes up with influenza it
came up with SARS it was a documented
you know one-off episode of some aerosol
transmission aerosol means that it can
stay in the air for a period of time
because it's in a droplet that's very
small and doesn't go down
is it possible and that there is aerosol
transmission yeah if certainly is but
clearly what we have seen in the
situations where people have gotten
infected from the areas that we have
experienced China South Korea now Europe
most of it is in a situation where
people are close enough to each other
that a symptomatic person will have a
real droplet transmission so I'm not
ruling out the possibility that it's
aerosol but again it's not gonna
substantially change doing this in a
very simple way what is the demand
pressure on testing in this country and
are we meeting it I get the same calls
that many of you get that someone goes
into a place who has a symptom and wants
to get a test and for one reason or
other multiple logistic technical or
what have you
they can't get it very far that is a
reality that is happening now is it the
same as it was a few weeks ago
absolutely not because as the secretary
and others have said right now that we
have the private sector involved the
availability not only just availability
but the implementation of the
availability is getting better and
better and better having said that I
understand and empathize with the people
who rightfully are saying I'm trying to
get a test and I can't that what you're
saying we are not yet at a point where
we are meeting the demand pressure
well the answer is yes John we are not
there yet because otherwise people would
be never calling up saying they can't
get a test Trump doesn't believe that
well I just can't emphasize enough about
the incredible progress that we have
made on testing all of your reporting
and media outlets around the country are
as well that that many many more tests
are being performed every day literally
by the tens of thousands and this has
only been made possible because several
weeks ago the president brought in the
commercial labs these enormous companies
quest and LabCorp working with companies
like Roche and in Abbott Laboratories
and thermo Fisher and said like we have
this existing system of state
laboratories and the CDC processing
tests for certain infections but given
the magnitude of this outbreak the
president had pre hend it early on that
it wouldn't be enough to meet the need
and whatever Adair can to know that
literally hour by hour in partnership
with these extraordinary commercial labs
we are making more and more tests
available every day we'll detail the way
that we're working with States to
distribute those tests we've obviously
focused on states that have been dealing
with with the most serious outbreaks of
coronavirus Washington state California
New York and others we've been making
sure the tests are in those areas
working closely with those governors but
I think the American people should be
encouraged at the progress that we are
making tomorrow will take some time to
detail that progress for you but I would
say to any American who might be
concerned that they have symptoms as the
president said so well we we don't want
every healthy American to get a test but
if people feel that they have symptoms
that they identify with the corona virus
call your doctor their doctor can call
their state health authorities that can
work very closely with our entire team
through
HHS and FEMA and work to identify the
more and more tests that are available
every day just just so you know just for
the 100 Ivanka's gun I this
administration inherited and obsolete
Obama broken bad system that wasn't
meant for this right we discarded that
system and we now have a new system that
can do millions of people as you need
them but we had to get rid of a broken
old system that didn't work it worked
only in a very limited basis and we're
very proud of what we've done
it's incredible what we've done and this
system will now see things that we
literally do not meet your problems
hopefully you don't have a problem like
this but something will come up we have
now a great system and it's almost fully
in gear but it's able to test millions
of people but we inherited a broken old
frankly a terrible system we fixed it
and we've done a great job and we
haven't been given the credit that we
deserve that I can tell you but the one
that really deserves the credit are the
American people because they are doing
things that nobody thought they would do
what they're doing is incredible and
we're making a lot of progress and we'll
see you folks tomorrow thank you very
much all right if you're watching on
YouTube before you leave please do hit
the subscribe button and also like the
stream appreciate the 41,000 people who
have stopped on by for this press
conference make sure to hit that
subscribe and like button before you
head out always very much appreciated
let me say thanks to some folks who
grabbed memberships while we were
chatting here constants alwah NASA is
new member number five that means one
free t-shirt or item will be given out
Derek Siler is new member number six
today Paula Hernandez is new member
number seven today
Bridgette Hagman is new member number
and I apologize I just got 20 text
messages and that's so rude of me okay
let me make sure I thank everybody
Brandon Hoover is new member number nine
today at join pakman.com Heidi Hirsch
BOC is new member number 10 that means
we'll give out a second free item from
the store to two of the first ten people
to sign up Jeffery Taylor today is new
member number 11
Salvatore Akana is new member number 12
as we have wrapped the press conference
Salvatore then we have who else do we
have here
want to make sure I didn't miss anybody
Glen Rodriguez is new member number 13
thanks for signing up at join pakman.com
and that catches us up there okay listen
let's address this issue of we don't
want to test everybody you don't need to
test all 340 million Americans that's
true but it would be useful to take an
area and to test everybody in the state
regardless of whether they've had any
symptoms if we had an antibody test Y it
would be that the tests that are widely
being used right now aren't antibody
tests meaning they can test if you have
an active infection if you have the
virus in you the pathogen once you fight
the virus off naturally at this point it
would all be naturally there's no
vaccine your body has antibodies has it
you you there are antibodies that show
that you are now it is believed immune
for a year or much much longer imagine
that we test a large group of people and
we find out that 1% have the virus but
10% have already fought it off people
mostly who didn't even know they had
symptoms that is incredibly important to
know about how widespread it has been so
in any case there are other countries
that have the antibody tests and we are
widely not using an antibody test at
this point in time a few super chats
that came in during the press conference
let's see here Ryan Henry Dean says
there was an old broken system part
that's true Bill Gates has said
yes but the idea that it's Obama's fault
is whacked
Sam Dean says Obama sheesh you're still
awesome Dave the grim raven says this is
why pence needs to be President Trump
should resign immediately turbo Jones
says can you imagine Biden dealing with
this seriously well he'd be dealing with
it way better than Trump would Charlie
says thank goodness Ivanka was very
strongly and powerfully at the briefing
besieged in a beautiful way yes Donald
Trump saying we were besieged in a
beautiful way a lot of people picking up
on that that's a good romance novel
title Ryan Neufeld says I wonder if
people were dying gruesome deaths like
Ebola if people would still want to take
a three percent chance David Trump
invested in malaria drug maker Gilead I
thought Gilead made REM des aveer or as
Trump called that yesterday run
reservoir not the not not chloroquine
ruby moon says I work in health care and
also take hydrochloric when it's
relatively safe but if it doesn't
improve symptoms significantly the side
effects aren't worth minimal relief fair
we need to investigate further
Wuhan strong worldwide stand as one
against the virus says the curio pop
name withheld says Chanel Rhian from Oh
a n was the misinformation agent saying
Kovac came from North Carolina yeah her
seat today seemed to be filled with Sean
Spicer which was weird I hate juice says
if core are people the give'em a
thousand like us
if core are people the give them I don't
know what that one means
Sam asks that I just quote full house
not that I'm aware of what what did I
say
Lorena Lou era says look up what malaria
drug side effects are and why and what
they have done to soldiers yes none of
these things are without side effects
name withheld says cut his mic he's
losing it Jane womanpower says check out
why Spicer is there please and report a
lot of people noticing Trump seemingly
coming unglued that it's turning into a
comedy show that he is unhinged
environmental Hoffa coffeehouse says I
can't get my hydrochloric win because
this president is full of bull it's for
my CEO grens which is an autoimmune now
I can't get my script I don't know I
don't know about that but that doesn't
sound good Ricky Williams says nikki
Haley steps down from Boeing PR move for
VP pair Terran says oops now the doctor
is smoked he corrected the dawn a lot of
people chiming in there all right
I've got to go and it is my lunch time
at this point I'm being flagged so
thanks to everybody who joined me there
may be another one tomorrow and if so we
will we will be covering it thanks for
joining me today remember like and
subscribe on the way out follow if
you're watching on twitch